the number one mistake that people are
making in life today is they're living
life in the middle I think the biggest
vulnerability you've got is you actually
value somebody's opinion more than you
value your own my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur wanna
soar get a mentor what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best and
Gary Vaynerchuk and his five secrets to
turning your life around mentor me Gary
also if you want to know what Gary and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my to 54 confidence
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
they like to join is in description
below the reason people don't put
themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one don't live in the middle the
number one mistake that people are
making in life today and it's and it's
just so unbelievably obvious is they're
living life in the middle you know 99.9%
of the people that watch or listen to
this content are living in the middle
there they're hedging and making excuses
and justifying why they are not 100%
happy it's because like every other
person out there besides a few select
people they are living in this middle
ground and I just say the middle and
when I think about how you win in
business and entrepreneurship the most
of all in life it's by understanding the
macro and micro opportunities and
executions if you really understand how
to break through how to be in that zone
how to really really really win the game
it comes down to a strategy that looks
like this are you balancing your ego
with your humility are you balancing
your ego with your humility do you Iike
lis think that you're the greatest of
all time and you can do it and that also
you're a piece of [ __ ] and nobody cares
when you're gone secret number two take
on responsibility the reason I say the
thing that if there's anybody that ever
looked like you that made it then
there's no excuse is cuz I believe it
you know it's really hard here in our
argument and that your friend tells you
that's great Gary but both my parents
were alcoholics and that really me up
right now you're on the defense that's a
good first punch by them am i cool we
don't need to use me if anybody has ever
been successful that had two alcoholic
parents which by the way I know of three
well then now what's your Excuse Karen
we are just so interested in blaming
everybody else and excuses cuz we don't
want to take on responsibility and some
were a long time ago I went completely I
only take I do you know
I think everything is my fault like all
of it like I think it's weirdly cloudy
outside right now and not nice out my
fault
like his scar my fault
like I just default into my fault and
everybody tries to do everything else
the other way and let me tell you how
good life becomes when you take on
responsibility it gets real good uh some
of you and there's a lot of you that
follow me you know why I keep bringing
up the last scene of eight mile the
Eminem movie how many people have seen
that movie great
the last scene they go into the battle
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the other person with
nothing the leverage is in being
accountable of everything the leverage
is exposing your weaknesses I proudly
talk about passing on uber twice being a
DNF student you know I proudly talk
about my shortcomings right I can't wait
for more bad things to happen I mean it
because I will talk about them because
what you're so imperfect thank you
secret number three ignore the noise I
think the biggest vulnerability you've
got is you actually value somebody's
opinion more than you value your own but
the reason I've been able to always do
my thing is when I was 24 and people
were like oh you work at your dad's
liquor store like I heard that it's like
a chip on my shoulder you know I loved
it how's that cool keep sleeping on me
you know like I'm glad you're on Wall
Street making a hundred thousand buying
BMWs and dumb jewelry I'll see you in 30
years you understand like to me the way
you win is you realize you can't hear
nobody not your parents I mean listen
you got to listen to coach and all that
I get it but at the end of the day my
guy yourself you got to get real real
quiet up here I can't hear anything
you go look at my Instagram right now my
first post I'll post something first
hundred replies in one second you're
Jesus
you walk on water you're the best you're
the old-time can't hear him the next
hundred you're a piece of your foolish
you're a snake oil salesman can't hear
him I'm in my own mind doing my own
thing
and that comes with self-esteem
everybody's trying to keep up with the
Joneses I'm not worried about you being
on the in the Hamptons on a blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear
I'm not worried you jump the fence and
took a photo in front of a private plane
what do you think these people are doing
they're posing patients long game you
know what's amazing about being an
entrepreneur we get to play forever
right I'm gonna be working when I'm 96
trying to find my next hustle secret
number four stick to your DNA the
ability to adjust is the entire game
like I'm so proud that I changed my mind
every day my dad used to get so pissed
when I was building wine library he
would always be like he's like he would
say like three months ago you said Ricky
was gonna be the best employee I'm like
I changed my mind he fire him or or he's
like you said sparkling wine was
important now you just eliminated it
from the key spot I'm like I changed my
mind like my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur like I
would never take a note like that scares
the piss out of me what these three
people are doing right now right and so
now you know now that may work for them
and I'm not like back to the opening
statement like you need to do you like
some plenty of people that make a lot
more money than me and one bigger take
notes the key the key though the key is
way too many people are doing like
here's a good one you know what really
pissed me the [ __ ] off what really
pissed me off in tech world was when
Steve Jobs his book came out when he was
dying when it was all about Steve three
or four years ago I literally watched a
lot of my tech startup friends start
being like a to their staff because jobs
was tough everybody fell into the
romance of like I have this big vision
and I'm gonna be a like Steve right and
I thought that was really interesting
for me to watch that half decade of like
literally watching people I know and
then watching them act differently
because the status or the icon of the
moment and you see a lot of that and so
like that is probably the energy I'm
trying to bring to this class today
which is you can look at like how people
roll and like it's great to admire and
things of that nature but it's so damn
and poor
and to stick to like your DNA right and
like what you're good at and to
recognize that you need to surround
yourself whether it's your co-founder or
whether it's the people that work for
you like all I do is hire the people
that are the opposite of me
that bring the other value that bring me
the ability to remember what that
meeting was about and go make sure it
happens you know like whatever it may be
right and so I think that's another
thing that I would HIGHLY recognize and
secret number five the last song before
a very special bonus secret is believe
sometimes a lot of people may try a new
initiative and then they don't get an
immediate reaction they and they think
it's a failure that's right I want to
get your YouTube videos with the Wine
Library you know you had so much content
out there how did you stick in there how
did you keep yourself motivated because
I believe in my strategies and I'm
patient ish like all great stuff
especially when you're innovating
doesn't happen right away this notion
that like Oh Gary I tried it I spent
five hundred bucks on Facebook Ads it
doesn't work well what if your video
sucked what if your product and service
sucks I I tend to do things that are
very early that has been my career you I
when I do things I believe in them I
stick with them based on intuition even
though for 18 months nobody watched my
wine videos at all I knew it was right I
was right there's been things I've done
that I've jumped off of very quickly I
started to Gary v app V chat ve like
WeChat that was funny for my fans great
CRM one on one didn't feel right after a
week or two spend plenty money building
it knew it stopped it after you know a
couple months Wine Library TV five years
everyday YouTube decided to change it to
daily grape insular app you could buy
stuff subscription for reviews it was a
lot of fun only did it for five months
stopped it because I didn't feel right
anymore it's always hard to know when to
jump off something new but I find that
people don't believe in what they're
doing they hear a guru and they do it
begrudgingly because their boss wants
them to or they're like well Gary's
right a lot so let me do it but they
don't believe it and so then they jump
they're looking for nose instead of yes
is everything I do every business
development every event I do every time
I try new marketing tactics or sales
tactic I'm looking
for the yes right I'm looking for the
yes and if the no punches me will then
on my crap then no punched me I believe
the majority of people when they try new
tactics are looking for the no mmm-hmm
and you're gonna getting a lot of subtle
knows immediately right and so I think
that's why that happens
I've got a special bonus clip with Gary
on how to take life by its throat that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
noise do you need to ignore today number
two how will you make that a consistent
habit and number three what will you do
the next time someone hates on your
ideas
just enough enough enough like living by
somebody else's rules is a humongous
mistake I just literally sat down with
five people under the age of 27 and it's
so refreshing it is so refreshing if you
have not jumped on the bandwagon of
doing exactly what the you want to do
which is skiing for the next three years
or working at a job that's not what your
parents want or what society wants this
video is just called enough enough make
this little one 2 minute video depends
on when I finish the piece of content
that gets you to stand up and take life
by its throat do something stopping
scared stop letting the way you were
raised the fear as an offense take that
away let me be the person I'll take the
blame
I loved that some of my plays are like
my parents don't love what you're saying
good parents because if you are playing
defense and if you are living a life
where your kids lives are the way you're
being fulfilled you're a loser
parents and so enough enough parents
imposing their way you want your kids to
be happy on your terms enough the kid
that's sitting right now in a desk and
saw this in a feed and you hate your job
enough stand up get the [ __ ] out of here
and do you live your life you've got one
life do something about it raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that passion and love one drop
of most self-worth depends on your it's
suppose to mean
if you want to know the six skills that
you need to master check out the video
they're right next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
if you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline
I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one